I paid $300 for this box and I have no
idea what's inside and it's so heavy I'm
about to buy a $300 mystery box somebody
puts a bunch of stuff in a box you have
no idea what it is you're basically
paying for the surprise of opening a box
of mystery I have bought a mystery box
before it was a $100 mystery box it was
filled with what can best be described
as weird junk it was exciting to open
though would it be even more exciting to
open even more expensive mystery box I
am hesitant to spend slush waste even
more money on another mystery box but
they were like you got to do it spend
the money just to clarify you want me to
buy an even more expensive mystery box
that's correct
even though there might be garbage
inside yes $300 is the maximum budget
I've been given
I found a mystery box that's exactly
$300 I feel better knowing that some
random person is getting this money and
maybe they really need it maybe they
have student loans maybe they're trying
to pay their rent you're not selling
mystery boxes on eBay if you don't need
money I just carried this box up two
flights of stairs and it's very heavy
$300 why did you spend that I don't know
man do you buy like everything in any
well nothing living which but to you
I've might expect
I know it's good fragile oh it's a
mystery it's fragile and you're letting
me shake it it's it's furniture are you
smelling it
you better believe I'm smelling not a
bowling ball it feels like book my mind
immediately goes to frozen meets
skeletons like human skulls or something
with Johanna these people are just
sharted you now they're just like this
girl on BuzzFeed is gonna buy this box
if I put it on eBay okay well I'm
terrified Oh God
okay the person who sold this box
spray-painted with gold spray paint 300
on every side of the box to indicate the
300 actual dollars that I spend on it
this box is fragile a lot of people have
shaken it already so that's not great
I'm getting nervous to open this what if
this is rocks I think this is a box of
rocks and now I'm upset okay you know
what we're just gonna open it we're just
gonna open it I already feel my heart
just dropping there's a lot of stuff in
here where to even begin okay magnetic
oil drain plug
cool this is my new $300 best friend
tiny bear I honestly don't know what
this is a camouflage backpack it smells
weird is this a kite this is a kite I
don't know why if I'm an exciting this
is a 3d wooden puzzle if you ever see a
deer that looks like this just run away
this says ballet fun exclamation point
but these little ballet dancers do not
look like they're having that much fun I
don't know what this is but the package
says wow this is amazing I feel like if
you have to say wow this is amazing on
the package it's not amazing
this is sunglasses that come in a box
with donuts on it and that's really
misleading in a mean way I think these
glasses claim to be the freshest shades
owner so let's all be the judge of
whether that's true
oh I think these glasses are priceless
can sunglasses smell musty yes they can
very musty what the hell this is a Happy
Meal toy from the movie ice age
continental drift this is a Twix box but
I don't think it has
Twix in it not what I expected a
necklace oh my god I didn't think it was
possible for like jewelry to smell bad
this is the worst telling jewelry I've
ever encountered this smells like a
sweaty gym there's another necklace oh
god a jump drive this will be good in
case I time travel back to 2004 this is
a big weird box okay interesting this is
an artist's rendering of John Lennon I
just saw some things that look like food
and I got excited
but then worried that you shouldn't eat
food out of a mystery box at the same
time I'm kind of hungry so we're gonna
see how this goes there is actual candy
in this mystery box oh it's not expired
I'm gonna see if anyone will eat these
but I don't think you should do you like
sour patch kids yes would you eat sour
patch kids that came out of a mystery
box no you wouldn't
no it's still good that expiration date
wise well I'm not worried about that and
worried about being poisoned yeah I
guess I would be there do you want those
yeah well will you wait eat one right
now if I die this is on you I know
[Music]
I'm not dead yet now I feel bad that I
made Chelsie eat one so I feel like I
have to eat one
it's fine there's still so much stuff in
here electrical tape this is something I
could actually use a light switch cover
these are little ceramic dishes with
wine glasses on them and one is super
broken and it says Cheers live life with
abandon this is a model racecar that you
can build yourself there is just one
more thing
in this $300 mystery box and it is a
ventilation fan one thing I learned
today will a $300 mystery box be any
less musty than a $100 mystery box no
just as musty if not musty er
there was no garbage in this box so
that's exciting my hands are definitely
covered in mystery box grime and I'm
excited to wash my hands after this if
you bump up the price of a mystery box
is the stuff inside gonna get cooler
probably not but will you increase your
chances of getting one very cool thing
maybe I think the most important lesson
that a mystery box can teach you is life
is full of disappointments often brought
on by yourself I just washed my hands
after touching everything in the mystery
box and no joke the water turned gray so
though some crusty stuff we all want to
know it was either a box